And the answer is the mean will double and so with the standard deviation.
To see put this again into our formula using our original mean, and now we realize
that the new salaries x' are twice the x salaries or put differently x will be a half of x'.
If I substitute this into the formula over here, I get the same exponential expression,
but now with half x' where the x used to be.
Now the trick is to deal with the half and that's more complicated than our case before.
The very first thing is I have to bring the half out of the parenthesis over here and there's a trick
whereby I rewrite 70,000 as a half of a 140,000 and you can see where this is going.
With that, I can now bring the half out of the square over here, which gives me a quarter,
you have to square the half with x'-140,000)²/10,000²
and now, all I have to do is I have to bring the quarter into the 10,000.
So quarter up here is the same as a 4 down here.
Now, you have to bring it inside the square, so we have to take the square root
so it ends up to be the same as the new 2, the square of 2 into the square over here.
So this transformation shows that doubling the salary doubles the µ but also doubles the σ.
It doubles the standard deviation of those salaries--I've proven it to you.